listen listen carefully
cuz I'm only gonna say this once there
are some websites on the internet they
should you should not go to and I'm not
talking about reddit tumblr or pewdiepie
talking about websites that will change
website that you wish you didn't go do
websites that makes you question
humanity Gunn I'm sweating already
okay so I got a list of the worst of the
worst no no my channel is not on there
[ __ ] you okay and I'm gonna go through
we're gonna go through them gonna go
through them alright
[Music]
number one clocks by I have not even
heard of half of these [ __ ] clocks
spider if it's on YouTube then it can't
be that bad Jesus Christ
is that real see that's this is why I
will never ever go to Australia what
does it live inside the clock or some
[ __ ] does this [ __ ] just keep taking
pictures of it not knowing it will just
attack her at any moment
yeah nice point [ __ ] hmm oh [ __ ]
that's creepy okay now this is this is
Clarke spider now I've seen Clarke
spider before alright well that's not so
bad
let's move on soggy biscuit a male
masturbation game the loser eats the
biscuits B and a few mates we're
planning a night and one of the guys
asked what we were doing I told him we
should be playing soggy biscuit
he replied while I'm not coming I said
well you'll be eating the biscuit then
you twice why am I wasting my time with
this let's move on trypophobia Oh God
not trip phobia
please oh [ __ ] me [ __ ] ass wipe
ah oh oh oh oh it's like a car accident
I I can't look oh I can't look away is
that a nipple circle-jerk next one I
know what circle-jerk is everyone I mean
everyone knows right okay let's move on
as scary Asus what is that
like worms I can't are you still here
why are we doing this skin condition
well that can't be that bad we'll just
we're basically googling Oh
all right two girls one cup I've seen
this when I was like 14 I can do it
again
I can do it again it's not a big deal it
stars off it stars off one wonderful and
it goes south so fast
[ __ ] did she eat what the [ __ ] is
[Music]
Oh
I didn't I [ __ ] dinner mucus plug
what is that okay
Oh No okay well that's you know that's
discussing and all but I there's no like
video or anything so I think we're okay
next one is peanut Dawg it's just a
really ugly dog honestly like it's kind
of cute it just looks like Satan became
a dog I don't I don't I don't see
anything bad with that spider porn this
one says it just don't buy this oh
that's a nice shine the production value
in this oh is that another dude okay
does he like it or does he not like it I
don't understand oh he likes it he's
he's into it how much did they pay him
cuz they can pay me okay that was that
was are you still here I don't
understand I don't party thank you for
watching this video uh I google them so
you didn't have to we did it together
high five and just have a great leave a
like and maybe I'll do the next ten on
the list if it gets more than six likes
I will do it that's it for now and as
always stay awesome press what is that
what what's that that must have been a
fish there must have been an octopus oh
it's a tiny penis